i'm here with singer songwriter and man
of the people luke bryan
uh twitter launched some deep and
meaningful questions our way and right
now luke and i are here to catch those
get it cause he fishes it's awesome
we're funny um
and we're gonna give them the proper
answers they deserve this is another
round of
kelly's corn twitter questionnaire
[Music]
here's how it works i will read some of
the most pressing questions we found on
twitter during the quarantine
then luke and i will help out with the
answers our first
on today's twitter questionnaire comes
from at miss austin2u who asks
if you could get an unlimited supply of
one item what would it be
give you one guess beer
it's a tie between beer and fishing
lures
[Laughter]
minus mine is i don't care what people
say they could claim that this is two
but it's not it's one because i never
want
one without the other chips and queso so
ah
yeah that's mine that is you know what i
had so
so i i had dinner the other night and
then my son after his baseball game
wanted to go
to have mexican and i'd already had
dinner and i still
ate like a bath yes
i mean you cannot not eat it it's
irresistible
it's so perfect it's so great okay cool
the next one is from at
temple which artist do you want to see
live when all of this finally blows over
when we were talking about this maybe
i'm gonna go see a uh the boss
bruce springsteen i've been throughout
quarantine i've really been
honing my my boss you know my boss
skills i've been i've been uh don't be
surprised if at my next show i'm i'm
i'm ripping you know i've got a few uh
yeah
[ __ ] moves on stage i love that
actually i'm gonna go that i want to go
with you and your wife to that show that
sounds fun i've never seen him live i'm
such a fan and i've never seen him live
i think he's got to do it i've got to do
this i have
met him and he was super kind and and so
is his wife but i
but yeah just super talented god what a
what a legend
um okay i have time for one more um oh
you have time for one more rather
um so that's the last quarantined
twitter question and it comes from the
appropriately named account
at ask twitter what useless talent do
you have
i can i can lay on a wooden floor
and make fart noises with my back
oh my god that's awesome um i'm just
gonna try that the next time i'm on one
point
um i only have one useless i mean it's
not useless i guess
i can i i'm the worst i have the worst
memory like especially if i write the
song like since i began singing like in
junior high i just have the worst memory
i just don't yeah and so i make up words
the last the last second i'll just make
up words and
nine times out of ten at rhymes doesn't
make sense but it rhymes
and i do it often there's a whole
blooper website about it but yeah that's
a
it's a talent but it's useless i should
just know the words but i forget them
do you ever do that do you forget the
words the only time i forget the words
when i'm in concert is if i'm reading
someone's sign
because yes it distracts me yeah like if
somebody like if they go
if their sign says i love you luke like
but if but if their sign has like
some interesting message that
you know my mother saw you in
you know my mother saw you in 1999 and
she wants me to tell you and
like and i start reading it then i'm
like i'm i like my brain is gone
i'm like happens to me all the time and
that's when i move into this mode using
yeah all right it is always good to see
you
um please say bye to carrie if you can
hear me i love your manager
um hey y'all y'all stay safe and stay
healthy and
it is always nice to talk to you luke
and everybody luke's new album is out
now it's called born here live here die
here
and for luke's special jalapeno
margarita recipe which i want as well
head on over to our facebook page
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel please don't make me keep going